I no longer have any reason to speak Slovak
I haven't done so for the last 80 odd years
and the very few words in my head.
...of pageants. And I can remember standing on the little stage
in the village hall in '?' with-
Sokol was this physical exercise movement.
1000s of us belonged. And the song I sang
was the song we used to sing as children
when we were going into the exercise class.
I couldn't tell you clearly what it was. But I did sing one.
And now I can't remember it.
Underneath Kriváň and Kriváň is one of the highest mountains in the Tatras.
If my geography still holds out. I never went to the Tatras.
And there's a good reason for that. A) I don't think my father
would ever afford a - a skiing holiday day for the family.
And I went to a Jewish school and every winter,
our playground was turned into an ice rink.
So we went skating and mother was a keen swimmer
and we swam in the Danube.
Before the late 1920s, the Danube used to freeze over
and people used to skate on the Danube.
And I even brought my shoes with the skates screwed in,
with me to England.
I haven't got them anymore, because I don't skate anymore.
It used to hang in our dining room come whatever it was,
it hung above our grand piano.
This room was between the room, which was our general room
in the flat and that general room contained-
we had a posh dining room, which also included our grand piano
with Judith hanging over the grand piano.
And we also had our cupboard cabinet,
which had our clothes in it.
And as well as that, my father had a very large desk,
with a telephone which was very unusual in those days.
And that was the desk at which he would do his writing.
And father and mother had twin beds pushed together
And the divan across the beds,
because Father used to have a nap after lunch,
because midday was when you had your main meal.
I very clearly remember the painting, because I was petrified of it.
And if I woke up and I was a bit afraid, I wanted to go in mother's bed,
I had to go through here.
With a grand piano there and she hung up on this side of the grand piano
And she used to terrify me.
There she is. There's Judith with a blooming head behind her skirt.
My sister and I learned piano, my brother learned violin.
Mother played the piano.
And father was very interested in opera and music.
So there was music in the house.
My brother used to make little crystal sets,
which we had a little thing,
you used to put your little pin in, and it would then make crackling noises.
And we used to listen eventually, to Mr. Hitler shouting.
And I remember that very distinctly.
Radios, I suppose were quite novel things in those days.
And father used to go into that room to listen to broadcasts.
And I can remember broadcasts of Hitler,
because he used to always shout when he was speaking.
I can't remember the contents because I think as a young child,
it wasn't of interest to me. We had a communal room
in which my brother sister and I slept.
We had our dining table, and father had his large desk.
And we had a telephone on the desk. So that was it.
There. The next door, we had this other in between room
where we had a grand piano and we had this fantastic painting
of Judith and Helofernes.
It used to frighten me a bit.
So I - my father was a banker -
I think most of the memory is just that it was there
above the piano. And that was all.
And that picture now hangs in my daughter's house,
because I haven't got room for picture, which is 4.6 ft by 4ft.
It was only after the war, when I started doing research on it,
but it was hidden during the war.
And eventually, through my eldest cousin, Igot to find out
that it had been hidden by, at my grandmother's farm,
by some peasants or something.
And it ended up in my uncle's house, after he had returned from Russia,
with the Czechoslovak army contingent,
which was within the Russian army at the time,
and he was a doctor, and it ended up in his house.
And then in the 1990s, after my uncle had died,
my sister and I went to where my uncle lived.
And it was called Senec. And we told his second wife
because his first wife had been murdered in Auschwitz with his daughter.
And this other lady had no idea that this painting actually belonged to
my side of the family and not to her.
So she was quite amenable for us to retrieve it.
And we brought it over to England.
My sister didn't want to have this large painting.
But there were two other paintings two some very much smaller ones.
And she was going to have one and my brother could have had the other.
But my brother didn't want any of things.
He didn't want anything to do with the Holocaust anymore at that stage.
Can you see her, I can't see her anymore?
Oh, well come up a bit further then.
Yes, let me just see if I can see her.
I can see her clearly enough.
Now I can see her better
And be able to see her better still.
Yes, I can see her now.
Hello, Judith. Haven't seen you for a bit.
I think it was painted in the 18th century for Ludwig the II
Or Ludwig the mad or whatever he was called.
And it's 4ft6 by 4ft.
It's got a beautiful frame. But Judith herself has fantastic little plaits,
a beautiful gown and a bejewelled sword,
which she's holding in her left hand and with her right hand,
Just behind her skirt, you can see the head of Holofernes.
It is sort of tastefully hidden, but obviously,
She has cut off his head and killed him.
And there she is standing, looking straight ahead of herself
When the picture came, because it's so large,
she didn't really have any room for it.
So she said would I like it in my house.
So I was very happy to have whatever came really,
because it's just about the only heirloom that we've got.
It's very striking. Whenever we had anyone coming into our house
for the first time, they would always notice the picture.
And we would always have a conversation about the story behind it
And where it had come from.
So it's now in the stairwell on the third floor of our townhouse.
It was really quite difficult to get up there,
one of my sons stood on the bannister.
It's sort of trying to manoeuvre this very heavy, large picture.
So I've no idea how we'll ever get it down again, really?
I see it every day when I come up and downstairs from my bedroom.
But yes, it's sort of part of my life, now, I suppose.
It's you know, the one very large, concrete thing
that has come from my mother's home.
So yes, it's got place, close to my heart, really.
It's the only thing really, that's come.
And is it very coincidental that I'm called Judith?
It's a guilt frame. And it's plaster work.
Decorated with flowers and bunches of grapes and leaves and things
They are quite intricate, but it's been quite damaged.
And to get it restored the frame and the picture
It would have been very expensive.
But we were also advised that actually that might
change the nature of it, so we decided that we would leave it as it is.
And I think it's more evocative, really, that it is damaged.
I think it just shows us a lot of history to the painting,
not just about the painting when it was painted,
but the the life of the painting, that it's travelled.
You know, hundreds of miles.
It's been in hiding.
I think it just adds to the story of the painting.
So I like it as it is